before we start here's a pop quiz how do
you kill a vampire
sunlight stake to the heart holy water
fire decapitation
silver bullet write your answer down and
we'll come back to it later
so previously we talked about the digest
and the attendant mental construct the
fiction space alternate universe that
stories exist in
inside our heads today we're going to
talk about boundaries
specifically we're going to be talking
about diegetic justification for
creepy garbage and how terrible and
flawed it is as an argument
so there's a bad habit that people have
gotten into it's nothing new but it's
becoming
more and more common and it goes like
this
hello this is folding ideas i recently
watched the anime women getting ripped
apart by orcs and was
you know disturbed by the seeming
perverse glee the show takes in the way
it frames the frequent
and excessive dismemberment of its
female cast members
in fact the entire purpose of the show
seems to be little more than showing
women being brutally violated by orcs
minor characters with little plot
significance are often subjected to two
or three-minute sequences that focus on
almost pornographic lens on their
suffering and the enjoyment the orcs
take in the process
dan olson is wrong to complain if he
thinks this is a big deal then he
clearly wasn't paying attention
the orcs were created by the dread god
who hates all light the dread god wanted
an army that would rape and shred its
way across the land of fool
so the orcs aren't just violent for no
reason they are compelled to be violent
it all makes sense if you were paying
attention to the backstory
this has become a pretty familiar
exchange over the last few years and the
base components
are this one some element of a movie
anime or video game is criticized
usually for racism or sexism
two fans defend it by citing in-universe
reasons for why the world of the text
is the way that it is here's the problem
fictional worlds aren't real and are
eternally mutable by
creators they are the sum of a giant
pile of creative decisions made by one
two a dozen a hundred different
individuals who took it from blank page
to finished product the only reason
anything is the way that it is
is because a writer chose to make it
that way the diegetic argument aims to
dismiss criticism at its core suggesting
that there aren't any problems with the
text
provided controversial elements are
internally consistent
with the rest of the story world in
slang terms this can be referred to as
the thermian argument in the sci-fi
classic galaxy quest
the thermians don't understand fiction
as a concept it doesn't
exist in their language and thus they
see all texts as historical documents
while not identical the root figure of
thought is similar here the digest is
given primacy over the text as a
cultural product the exact rationale
behind a thermian argument may even end
up being contradictory from one case to
another
one medieval game with dragons and magic
but no one with brown skin
is fine as is because historical
accuracy
in a different medieval game a character
wears a chainmail bikini to a war zone
because it's just a fantasy and
that's just how her tribe dresses you
cannot criticize the world because
that's just the way the world is
this is a deeply flawed argument because
once again
fictional worlds aren't real and are
eternally mutable by creators
none of it actually exists the only part
that does exist is the finished text
and the idea that it represents so let's
go back to the quiz
how do you kill a vampire it doesn't
matter what you wrote the answer is
irrelevant
vampires aren't real while the rules for
how to kill a vampire may be codified
within any given game movie book or show
nothing exists to enforce the rules of a
fictional space
writers routinely alter the rules to
suit their interests and the needs of
their story
so in the world outside the diegesis in
our world
only the implications and impact of that
fiction
actually matter that's why this type of
dismissal
using a diegetic justification to
nullify
criticism is ultimately a chump argument
unlike world history where there is a
theoretical objective truth that we can
seek to better and more accurately
represent
fictional worlds are fiction there is no
truth to move towards
arguments for purity or consistency miss
the point entirely
the thermian argument therefore serves
only to shut down discussion
criticism of a creative work is
ultimately criticism of the decisions
that people made when they were putting
it together and
that's where we're going to leave things
for today now go in peace my children
in the name of like share and subscribe
amen